do you think aoc might be president one
day yeah
possible possible and but
two things number one
it's fast
number two
it's going to go in the following
direction i would guess
you begin
with the most
moderate
calm
non-confrontational
socialism you can imagine so not aoc or
bernie
no no they they are not confrontational
in my judgment in terms of the ideas of
socialism i mean they're both very
feisty they're feisty personally but not
but not ideologically
you know she is
bernie is also
you know in in honest moments and they
both really are pretty honest folks at
least in my experience
um
in honest moments bernie will tell you
that his what he advocates as democratic
socialism is pretty much what fdr was in
the 1930s
it was a kind of popular
government tax the rich a lot more than
you do now to provide a lot more support
for the working class than you do now
that's not a fundamental change that's
what he means by socialism when he talks
about it and he's asked for examples he
mentions denmark a lot okay that that
that's consistent that
that's the softest kind of socialism and
that's where we're going to start in a
country coming out of hibernation
pretty soon it's already happening
there'll be people who need and want to
go further in the direction of socialism
than bernie and aoc are comfortable with
you can already see that the shoots of
it now you know aoc voted
together with most of the others to
support the money for ukraine
okay that a lot of people in the in the
socialist movement do not support that
uh and that's gonna i don't know exactly
how that's gonna work out but
that should give people an idea there
are disagreements
you